guys what's up we are back on the road
again as the Impractical Jokers tore the
United States of America
impracticaljokerslive.com we're going to
be in Reading Pennsylvania Pittsburgh
Camden New Jersey Boston
Prudential Center in Newark and UBS
Arena Long Island just to name a few all
the tickets are on sale right now we're
touring through July and we're adding
more dates and practicaljokerslive.com
I'm going to every single one Cleveland
baby February 1st and 2nd early show
sold out still some Tiki wikis for The
Late Show I believe February 3rd Athens
Ohio University of Ohio University in
Miami yay February 16th 17th Stanford
Connecticut a new club there called New
York comedy club February 22nd Vancouver
kicking off the uh just for last Fest
February 25th San Jose the California
theater use the code Chrissy uh
pre-sale's probably over actually by now
San Jose California California Theater
February 25th February 26th Sacramento
the Crest theater and then at the end of
March we got West Palm Beach we got
Miami and then April is Austin Texas and
may is Buffalo New York Chris D
comedy.com for ticketwiki's brand new
hour of stand-up material this is what
you'll see this is what I'll try to put
out uh either on um Netflix HBO or Louis
CK's website christycomedy.com baby I
got brand new uh brand new materials so
come check it out and I'll make fun of
you
hey what's up it's Chrissy Boston cream
donuts listen we had two shows on sale
at the Wilbur in Boston March 24th they
both sold out so we added shows March
25th christycomedy.com for Tinky Wiki's
brand new hour of standard material in
Boston I love you I'm the new Paul
Revere baby okay so come to the show and
stick a Boston cream done up up my ass I
won't care at all all right I love
Boston so much I want to keep doing
shows at the Wilbur I want to move my
family into the Wilbur I want all of
Puerto Rico to be at that [__] Wilbur
okay you better come to the little bear
foreign
[Music]
Just Call My Name you know hey babe
don't you know baby
[Music]
Just Call My Name
is
wow nice that's it Sal we got our guest
Danny lapore what's going on guys little
did we know we picked that song That's A
Soulful little ditty yes and little did
I know that you could do a run like that
oh yeah yeah I'm just saying it no I I I
found that because you texted me I I saw
you singing a really [__] funny song
and I was like damn you got a voice yeah
yeah can I see your nipples girl oh yeah
dinner plates yeah dinner plate nipples
nipples classic Banger Danny Laporte can
we get a little of that right now yeah
sure uh which one was it I need to know
the size size of your nipples let me see
your nipples girl yeah all the dinner
plates
and I don't want to know what your
nipples look like
let me see the signs baby yes oh my God
it's beautiful yeah it's really like
it's a song you can listen to on repeat
it sounds like buttery velvet yeah yeah
yeah it was hard being an Italian
growing up with a singing voice because
if it wasn't like Frank Sinatra my dad
would be like what is this dog so do
people sing in your family uh yeah my
dad sang uh he was in the choir when he
was a kid
um and both of my brothers sing but I'm
like the most known for my singing
because that's like what all my content
was yeah well this thing being a capable
voice yeah but then there's a legitimate
singer oh yeah you guys yeah yeah I
guess I've got a door I'm gonna do
American Idol no no no no no no because
then you got like people in there I
don't have like a good enough backstory
for there like okay you know what I mean
like no one in my family's like died in
the Army right you know you know you got
that you got the run though yeah I got
the run I'm dressed like Floyd
Mayweather
I've never seen anyone pull off a track
shoot and then a uh uh like a button up
like a nice dress shirt nice Supreme
Uptown everyone thinks t-shirts I've
never seen anyone with a button-down
shirt underneath and it's nice it's got
to be Class A yeah you got to be classy
I appreciate it
yeah with my Gildan tube socks yeah but
it works actually you know we usually
shout out people I just want to say
thumbs down for our first time to Gildan
I don't know they had tube socks but I
can't take a Gildan t-shirt I can't get
your act together it's like sandpaper
that you sewed together it's a big box
yeah not for him it's it's the sizes are
all off the sleeves are big the chest is
too long I see a Gildan I want to run
the other way give me something like a
bella canvas something like that yeah
you know what I mean unless we're
printing it on merch then gildan's
awesome
[Laughter]
that didn't do Gildan merch and I get
like I have like a dollar profit a shirt
I did that yeah I did that once too I
was like I'm gonna make the coolest
sweatshirts of all time and they were
like 78 dollars to make and I sold them
for like 79 yeah and I made no [__]
money and everyone's like yo these
things are hot like when you put them
out again I was like never same same you
can't do it but yeah Gildan is like
sleeping uh with like two [__] things
of sandpaper on your back and on your
stomach I mean no I mean no distance
respect to all the people and the
families that killed him right but they
must know I think Gilda knows what
they're doing they know like they're
like we make cheap [__] we just make a
lot of money and they don't care they
don't care about the product they're
quality over quantity I know but they
shouldn't they run the game almost until
the last few years they shouldn't be
running the game with that kind of
business model no I went to a Travis
Scott concert once and all of his merch
was gilded no yeah really no way my
balls are blown off yeah that's he's
nerve Travis Scott that's yeah he wants
to try there's a grand for a low top one
yeah and he's going to give me a t-shirt
with a Gildan on it yeah that's the
thing about sneakers too though I know
you're a sneaker head like me uh but I
won't pay over retail for a sneaker ever
okay I can't I can't I can't justify it
because it's it's it's me like every
time like see these yeah I got them from
Supreme okay
there's no way I could pay 200 for an
uptown I just can't do it you have to
wait in line for those no no no okay
I've made it high enough or I'm
connected that someone will hold me a
pair somewhere yeah yeah so you know
what I mean but so you have a plug
that'll hold you or you have a you have
contacts at stores I have contacts at
stores but then I also have like a plug
that will get me something for retail
and I'll give them a tip and he'll get
you something that's going to be a hype
path for retail yeah like um uh the you
know the Virgil uh the off-white canary
yellow sure uh the Air Forces yeah I got
them for retail the Brooklyn ones too
wow what do you have to give to them do
you have to give sing them a song what
do you have to do no a lot of those
times it's just like uh I'm one of those
guys that walks in the stores that I
really like and just hopes that someone
knows me there yeah you know what I mean
we're all guilty I I do I got my plug a
kid but but but when I go I oh people
are like oh here's my number I always
feel bad no I had somebody at uh
Concepts but did you get lobsters I did
yeah for retail yeah see then what
that's what do you you know how about
this you bring joy into a lot of
people's lives yeah the least that you
could do is pay retail for a [__]
sneaker they gave me friends and family
on top of the retail damn
that's another level of famous if you
know I went in there with Jola Puma
that's not oh okay all right I got the
greens and the purple and I got fear of
gods and I got wave Runners all in one
shot off Below Retail every single one
absolutely it was the best thing I've
ever happened to me yeah I know I I've
retired my wave Runners for a little bit
yeah yeah
is that guy who makes Puma sneakers
complex no um okay uh he's the guy that
like walks around he's like Armenian I
don't know what he is but he like he
like walks around and like uh does um
like oh uh sneaker shopping on complex
I'm not in the sneaker world at all I
don't know anything about it it's a
world that people you know I mean these
are I like these yeah because you play
basketball in them one year yeah
probably when I was a kid I played ball
in them but whatever happened to you
Louboutin sneakers my Louboutin sneakers
that uh that um
Jasmine got them for me as a gift I was
like I don't want these she's like I
thought it'd be nice to match my
Louboutins was like okay so I
unwillingly paid for the Bolton and I
don't want I mean whatever you want to
wear wear but I the last thing I don't
they look I don't like them at all she's
like but the bottoms it's all about the
bottoms I'm like why would I buy a shoe
if people care about the bottom of the
sneaker yeah we got to give them
uh I actually [__] don't I'd love you
to put them on right put those on right
now should I it's either that or give
them the George Santos yeah
so there was there's a time when Sal and
I were going on the road when I was
opening for Sal we would go to a city
it's I was always going to like a
different gift shop different sneaker
shop and Sal one time I remember you
were just in the [__] best when you
were like I was like oh look at those
sneakers you're like I'm buying for you
I was like I felt like a side piece I
loved it right and then he bought these
for me and then I I knew he got them
there I forgot I got them twice since
then I've bought re-bought them because
I've done it
by I'm down to do that I don't mind
wearing the sneaker and then it gets
dirty and then you just buy it I do it
all the time at once do you buy two at
once yeah I'll buy uh one the stash and
one the trash yeah okay I have the most
I have of one shoe is four but that's
only because it went on like crazy
clearance and I had paid full price for
it originally right it was just like a a
special edition like a high top van with
horween leather which is like this the
oldest leather company and then it went
on I bought them for like full price
then I saw them online for like 50 bucks
a pair so I bought three more pounds one
time I was at a fat Joe concert and um
and uh me too he
busted a hole through the front of his
sneaker uh somehow like or or the
somehow a sneaker bust open on stage was
that BB Kings and I I was standing there
I was standing off to the side and I saw
the sneaker and he goes ah [__] and he
goes he goes I don't want this [__]
and he throws the like busted sneaker
into the crowd and somebody catched it
and then some guy who had like a book
bag makes a [__] beeline he was like
I saw it all happening he's like I'll
give you any amount of money for that
sneaker give me that sneaker and now and
the guy was like uh okay and he just
gave him this [__] busted sneaker and
then he opened up his bag and he had had
like other types of now I don't know if
they were all busted shoes but he had
had sneakers in that bag like loose
sneakers I was like what does this guy
do with a busted broken Fat Joe shoe was
there anything busted in what way
he busted a hole through it like he was
the glue it was probably an older
sneaker like a retro sneaker and the
glue dissolves in them oh that's why he
wanted to do so bad it's probably
something yeah yeah that's why the kids
that's what it was where are your shoes
but what are you gonna get for an old
worn broken Fat Joe I don't know that's
kind of memorabilia because he's wearing
like an 85 you know like I don't
remember what the shoe was but I do
remember Jasmine because we I I've been
doing a show with him at the time so we
knew we were in backstage and Jasmine
got drunk and said you look like an
Easter egg because he was wearing a
light oh no no no he was wearing a light
blue filon velor or not Fila light blue
velors and she's like can you look like
I'm packed in Easter egg I swear to God
and I had just like and I didn't really
know him that well and he was like yo
whose girl is this and I at first I was
like looking around you know and then I
I she was like looking at me so I was
like sorry like she's drunk um you know
he's like I'm white he's like just keep
her over there I was like
no that's a good thing though because
this is what you need to no I don't know
how deep in the hip-hop you are but Fat
Joe at one time was one of the most
feared people in music right like The
Terror Squad like yeah that was their
name for real yeah like they would stab
[__] they'll kill you kill you
cut [__] faces like uh Big Pun
like Chase Jay-Z around uh uh billiard
table with like uh with a champagne
bottle like those [__] were
crazy well he was easy to get away from
no big punishment yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah all right but then I remember
but then so I didn't think that he
remembered that right three weeks ago
I'm at a Knicks game
see Fat Joe comes you know saying oh hey
what's up man he goes hey what's up dude
he was like you still with that Puerto
Rican girl I swear to God I was like
yeah because we had a second kid he goes
oh
[__] and he goes he goes wait a second
wait a second is it is it that is that
one that called me the Easter Egg and I
was like yeah he was like all right and
then he didn't kind of say anything he
didn't love he didn't hate it but he was
like oh all right but I was like Wow
damn dude and then till to this day Jazz
will be like I never said that I'd be
like okay yeah you didn't say that I
[__] literally you said that and I
literally was thinking about either
walking away if she was pregnant with my
first child by then I was thinking about
walking away from that just saying you
know what not worth it or like I was
thinking like how are we gonna get out
of this green room with like all these
people because it kind of got silent
yeah the Terror Squad he was like who's
girl is that God damn I have two Fat Joe
experiences let's do it this is the Fat
Joe experience
put on your headsets now uh no one time
in like I mean it was like I was in
young 20s and I was at a wave Street I
don't know if you know Staten Island
yeah wave Street do you know what off of
Bay Street Bay Street waves I did wave
sheet is right off of Bay Street in that
particular area that was like all the
bars on Staten Island in like the 80s
and 90s none of them are there now not I
don't think so but it was like no it was
like literally like 20 bars in a half a
mile really like that and it was like on
the weekends the streets would be just
flooded with people I swear to God it
was a whole different vibe and they used
to have underage why would they get rid
of all the bars a lot of fights out of
underage drink a lot of [__] I don't
know really I'm not part of law
enforcement or I wasn't part of Congress
or anything like that so I don't know
right right but you can be it could be I
could do anything I want to really but I
I absolutely we went we saw him and and
and and he was supposed to play wave
Street and everyone's waiting and
waiting it's getting late he's not
coming on he's not coming on like what
the [__] is going on and then like
really late like two hours late someone
comes out and goes hey yo yo he's like
So Fat Joe
doesn't feel well
he's like Fat Joe most likely has the
flu
so I'm going to tell you something right
now he wasn't even going to come out he
wasn't going to come out for all but
he's gonna come out with the flu and do
one song for you and then he came out
and everyone just started [__] booing
and throwing [__] at the stage and he
was like [__] you [__] it and he walked
off and then his whole crew is up there
and he was like [__] you Staten Island
they were like you will be not doing
that Wu-Tang and they [__] cursed
everybody out and walked on this was
skinny Joe it was Fat Joe he was fat he
called him Fat Joe yeah you know what
when I did the show with him I think
I've said this on hey babe before I we
were sitting there in the green room and
you know by this time I known him a
little bit I was like what is the seat
like how did you lose so much weight and
he was like black cherry seltzers
[Laughter]
yeah I don't drink soda you drink soda
no I don't drink I'll have the
occasional Diet Coke like once a month
at like a restaurant or some [__] like
that but I love Diet Coke yeah what's
your Fat Joe story Oh My Fat Joe story
was I was 14 years old I went to the do
you remember the entertainers basketball
classic yes they would have at Rucker
Park so they would have like these
amazing summer leagues where like every
rapper would like buy their own team so
it would be like the Rockefeller team
the bad boy team The Terror Squad team
and I remember uh so I'm standing there
I got there about seven hours early
before the game because the games would
be crazy right like people would be up
like in the projects like hanging out of
the windows watching the [__] games
like all the way down there so I'm in
there and uh Cameron's team comes in
team Dipset comes in nice and they're
all like walking in but like they're
pushing everybody to get to the to get
to the court and I'm like 14 and like
5'4 and 108 pounds so I'm getting like
[__] like actually trampled like by a
bunch of people because like dipsets
coming through Cameron's dress like a
[__] popsicle you know what I mean
like you know what I mean like just
fresh as [__] and I'm just like yo this
is crazy but like I'm getting killed at
the same time and out of nowhere Fat Joe
appears and he puts his arm around me
and was like yo yo like yelling out the
crowd yelling at the crowd like yo chill
like chill chill got kids out here kids
out here and Fat Joe looks down at me
and just all this fat glory and just
goes shorty you good
and I literally look up and I'm just
like
yes Mr Mr Jones
yes Mr fats Like Fat Joe probably saved
my life so I owe it wow he really is a
great guy I sat next to him at a Nick
game one time I was in between
him and Ben Stiller and Ben Stiller's
son all right no no no sorry Matthew
Broderick right Matthew Broderick or
Matthew broderick's son and I I every
time like the Knicks did something I was
like yeah and I'm like you know like no
fat jokes
yeah yeah but like I I don't he didn't
let on that he knew who the [__] I I
don't think he knew who the [__] I was
at all right the whole time I was every
time I was like trying to give him like
a fist pound every time he did yeah that
like old school like 90s rap those those
guys were like just the best like I
don't I'm not in rap I don't know much
about rap but it just feels I would
assume different now the early Arts I
think was the last of what I felt that
rap was for me between the 80s and the
early Arts like I can't what's an art
like the the 2000s the early 2000s those
are called the Arts yeah well
but where does that come from uh it's a
phrase for a numeric isn't it a a u g h
t I've never heard this word but but but
like like what like unless I'm saying it
wrong this whole [__] time could be
it could be your action but I don't
understand like where it where that like
how would 2002 where are we getting art
uh I don't know yeah it's a-u-g-h-t but
where does it come from it's some kind
of number thing referring to the decade
between 2000 and 2009 yeah but but there
has to be an explanation of where they
got art out of because I would say like
this this word means zero the meaning is
zero odd so why can't we just say oh
because they don't want to say the zeros
well the 2010s
right so if you told me the 2010s I
would understand but if you told me the
2000 zeros I would understand that
better than the odds yeah you said hey
hey um the zeros yeah I would get that
the tens the 20s early 2000s early 2000s
to me early 2000s means anything from
2000 to 2009 I'm saying the early 2000s
okay I I'm fine with that I'm not really
I'm not here that's that's the entire
two thousands oh wait because we are
technically still in the early 2000s
yeah I mean we're in the we'll be in the
early 2000s for another 300 years
technically that's right right oh yeah
it will be in the early 2000s for
another yeah at least 300. I would say
once you get to 2400 now we're in the
mids mids they're also calling it The
naughties
n-o-u-g-h-t-i-e-s that's what's the
reason for that
ought not naughty nobody wants were we
naughty in the 2000s yeah I guess you
were kind of naughty I do feel 2000 I do
have a love affair I think again when I
was born I feel like the 90s are more I
like the 90s better than the 2000s like
when you tell me 2007 I don't know
what's happening well tell me 1997 I
know where I'm at oh yeah yeah for sure
yes uh
that was about it Sinead O'Connor ripped
up the picture despite the Real Enemy
we've talked about this though because
Lauren Michaels was like no never again
she's never coming back here yeah uh we
talked about this though because I I
think it's just because where you are in
your life and your age I don't know how
old you are I'm 30 gonna be 34 next week
God bless you you always [__] yeah
yeah I hated getting that okay Boomer
yeah I was like that got so annoying
that's gone now but I'm like my parents
are Boomer yeah well how old are you 46
46 38 38. we got a nice mixing yeah we
got a nice mix we would have went to
high school together you would have been
a senior when I was a freshman freshman
yeah you would have [__]
you good short are you good yeah yeah
yeah no I did have a vice principal that
tried the molest me once though really
yeah oh my God you guys want to get it
was it my suit guy yeah yeah I was gonna
get into the odds for a second
molestation
yeah yeah so when I was in high school I
was a troubled kid but like you know I
was just like uh
[__] like a bad student I was one of
those kids that was afraid to be stupid
so I didn't try okay you know okay so I
was like [__] map like you know like
[__] you and then like remind you you
miss 100 of the shots you don't take yes
Wayne Gretzky that's right yes yep
vesi is a company that has come into my
life recently like gangbusters literally
I've been saying this every time it's
the only rubber I wear vessi shoes it
vessi shoes are
do you want first of all can I talk to
you for a second what about the the the
the snow ones the vessey storm burst yes
yes those the scoreboard that's what
they're called they're the best shoe to
have in the winter no that's the best
show I've ever had in my life I ordered
a pair of Essie shoes they came they're
waterproof they have this patented
technology not water resistant they're
waterproof right I put them on I'm not
joking you know I'm a sneakerhead yeah
they were as comfortable as the most
comfortable sneakers I've had I
investigated further they had these
awesome all-weather boots that have like
their big big rubber like on the bottom
yes yes for traction yeah and then
they're like soft and they like they
lace up high right at the Stormer and I
I got those two I got a second pair wow
and I've been wearing them in inclement
weather like like I'm who knows what
they see shoes I like you said
waterproof they got that super soft knit
material that keeps your feet warm in
the cold your feet they are never gonna
get cold with vests it's like everything
that a rubber boot is like a water
resistant removed but it's like in a
sneaker version yes yes it's awesome and
um we love Essie and warm they're warm
and they're my go-to shoes by the door I
always say you know people to choose
take out the trash go get the kids the
investors are always by my door because
they're so easy they slip on they slip
off and they keep the feet warm hashtag
versatility I love it that's what the v
stands for if you just go to vesi.com
hey babe put in that promo code hey babe
put in the code hey babe and you're
gonna get a beautiful pair of Vesti
shoes for 15 off so you will get 15 off
your entire order if you just go to
vesi.com hey babe put in that promo code
hey babe 15 off your whole entire order
with vesi uh yeah try them out let us
know what you think guess what my new
name is in the streets Lionel Messi
what is it Lionel Messi instead of
Lionel Messi
Argentina
rocket money burning out your old uh
subscriptions
and saving you money money rocket money
the average person that uses rocket
money how much do they save a calendar
year do you know oh I know we're not
even I know what I've been looking 700
720 720 unbelievable you should be
called true bill that's right but now
it's rocket money by the way I've been
seeing rocket Money commercials all over
me too rocket money is
[Music]
we have been with rocket money and now
to see them on television I'm glad that
we were able to give them the Boost they
needed I think that we're we're vital in
that I think that without without us
rocket money is not on Super Bowl
commercials what is rocket money
well what rocket money is is you know
how when you go into your like you have
all these things that you some your
subscriptions that you've forgotten
about Rockets tell me about it they
canceling unwanted subscriptions right
and that's what they are yes and I used
it and I immediately cancel three
subscriptions that I knew I had that
were equaling up to like 26 and so the
first time I put I download the app and
hit a button I saved 300 I swear to
Christ personal finance app that finds
and cancels your unwanted subscription
to monitors your spending and it helps
you lower your bills all in one place
and we can tell you folks that this
stuff works okay rocket money stop
throwing your money away and cancel
unwanted subscriptions and manage your
expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com hey babe that's
rocketmoney.com slash hey babe
rocketmoney.com hey babe
where's Gretzky lately uh he owns a team
I think he owns does he own like the
does he only you don't hear about Knox
or something you still hear about Jordan
you still hear about everybody you know
you don't hear about Gretzky you hear
about Gretzky's daughter more I know big
fat titties her wedding she had some
crazy wedding or something yeah she
married a professional golfer Dustin
Johnson who plays live golf that's Saudi
Arabian Blood Money leak no Cristiano
Ronaldo playing that Saudi Arabian Blood
Money Beyonce just did the blood money
too and the WWE just I think sold them
Saudi Arabia on this part to Saudi
Arabia yeah dude what's the Saudi Arabia
gonna get into the podcast game yeah I
need something to offer is Right Saudi
Arabia if you're listening and we know
that you are yeah shout out Saudi Arabia
Good Vibes Good Vibes I love kingdoms
you're buying up a whole bunch of [__]
over here we have an IP that you could
buy yeah I mean now that Beyonce did it
we get a pass no no sure yeah we're all
fully clothed yeah yeah come on dude
what kill yeah the women will keep their
heads so this guy yeah so my voice yeah
yeah so my voice
from now on Saudi Arabia how much do you
yeah he's on the deal with the contract
we'll go from there yeah we'll cover the
hair up go ahead imagine like Saudi
Arabian like podcast reads
like you know what's you know it's good
oil yes
I love oil they would just be all
[__] oils.com hey babe yeah yeah I
need a new Rolls-Royce yeah
normally America's number one meal kid
we'd have to say death to America's
number one meal kid
but yeah my vice principal molesting me
um oh yeah yeah so when I was a kid I
was a little troubled had some issues
um so he like took me under his wing and
his thing was like he would take like
troubled kids like under their wing and
like
help me get back on the basketball team
like help me get back on the football
team because I would get academically
suspended all the time
and in the beginning I was like this
guy's the coolest guy ever and for
people out there if you're young and an
old man turns out to be the coolest guy
ever odds are he wants to have sex with
you yeah I'm just putting it out there I
don't know the statistics on it but odds
are when an older man is cool to a
younger boy that isn't related to him uh
sorry once you're back well hold up
unless that man of Saudi Arabian then
he's a good guy yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay contact us at what hey babepod
gmail.com yeah Saudis
I didn't even notice it wait wait but
you just said that right but I'm like an
older guy that's nice to kids yeah all
real old as [__] yeah like you're old as
[__] yeah and you don't work in a school
okay yeah yeah but if I was I'd be
really nice to the kids yeah would you
guys be nice I mean I think I just want
to make sure we're not painting
ourselves as less as if we're nice to
children oh no I'm nice to children all
the time I know you said you were nice
to my kids the other day yeah you never
know though but I'm still I'm still she
has been quiet yeah
I know she's my daughter's hiding in the
basement
Sal's coming she's like oh it starts
but um
yeah so
I was like oh man this guy's really cool
um obviously he was was grooming your
boy so I was just like okay like this
guy is really cool what was some cool
things about him
um he would get me he would take me out
of class like if I was having a hard
time if I was 30 minutes late for a
class he would write me a pass
um he would make sure that like if I was
failing I would get like that one
assignment that you do at the end of the
semester to pass okay so he was doing
like all these great things and I was
like damn like this dude sees my trauma
you know what I mean so I was like you
know this guy knows me a guy could read
me so um we're talking
um for two years like just regular right
and then like towards the middle of my
sophomore year
um
he pulls me into his office
and he goes I have a workout routine for
you
so I was like all right cool I played
football at the time so I was like yeah
you know what I mean so that's kind of
cool and then he was like yeah like if
you ever want to come here and work out
of my office you can if you want okay
which listen still is like it's weird
but we're not anymore yeah it's still
not molest area yeah you know what I
mean I can still see it being on the up
and up yeah my office yeah that's
sharing common space like I'll do
push-ups at 14 while you're you know
write progress like that yeah yeah if he
was there like watching you yeah Oh I
thought you mean like there was some
free weights there he's like come in no
no no no no no
um so
so so that was the first I have two
older brothers okay so I knew what was
gay very early on okay because I was
called Gay from the time I was three
okay you know because when you have two
older brothers You're gay that's just
how it is yeah yeah the little one is
gay yeah you're a little gay bastard so
that's just like what it was so I had a
clue and plus I was one of those kids
that like watched Oz like I wasn't
supposed to but like I watched this
stuff if you were up on the on it yeah I
was up on all that type of stuff but I
never he was really good at hiding The
Vibes so um he was doing that uh the
workout thing was a little weird and
then like a week later I had a bad day
in school and he brings me into his
office and he starts crying
and I was just like you good bro like
are you all right short are you good
shorty yeah short are you good yeah yeah
sure yeah Fat Joe them I was like yo
shorty good in that moment you called up
Fat Joe
this was like three days after the
tournament
so I'm just like yo I'm like what the
hell's going on man he was just like no
like I see like you're struggling so
much and like you know as a kid I
struggled too and I was like all right
cool like damn like what'd you do like
like tell your Spanish teacher like suck
your dick or something he was like no
he's like I had this track coach
and I was like all right and you just
like always like riding me like always
trying to like be a dick to me so I'm
like all right not gay okay keep going
yeah and then and then he's just like
and then um you suspected something
right now you felt uneasy yeah my gay
flag went up I mean and how old are you
right now I'm 34. no no how old yeah
yeah I was 14 and am I and like okay I
don't want to say gay but my molestation
flag went up all right oh yeah the big
red mullet I could be in a situation
right here yeah yeah yeah so
uh he started crying he starts like
talking about this coach and like you
know like when people are telling a sad
story they're like so I had this coach
yeah yeah fighting back yeah
yeah yeah
like whoa this is gonna be [__] heavy
because if anyone ever does that
mid-story it's gonna be like something
bad's coming after this because you know
they do not want to tell the story right
so he's just like yeah so like this
coach was always mean to me uh and
always and then like one day I was in
the shower and he like came into the
shower like naked with me oh
so now in my mind I'm like damn that's
crazy and then my mind immediately goes
to
why the [__] is he telling me this is
right right like I got in trouble in
math class like it's not like my math
teacher pinned me up against the [__]
Blackboard right maybe dude right you
know like equation like one time I was
doing long division nude and the guy
walked in nude with me and did it yeah I
was like yo what the [__] well you're
only 14 like people go in the shower
naked I only ever go into the shower
with my bathing suit
I was yeah no I'm like that too I'm a
shy guy but um I remember just being
like he's like yeah and you like got
real Vivid he was like he pushed me up
against the thing and I was just like yo
what like I'm supposed to go to [__]
gym after this like how am I supposed to
process she was like I just don't want
to like see the same things happen to
you and I was like
okay I was like all right like Mr blank
I was like it's all good like uh and
then I'm consoling like this like
molested older man right in his office
this guy's like 50 years old dude I'm
14. he's telling me about how his gym
teacher like tried to tickle his venous
you know what I mean like it's kind of
crazy so I'm just like okay and I
remember I just go back to class and I
was like
I feel bad for him but there was
something incredibly weird about that
right yeah right across them incredibly
gross like why is he telling me this
like I'm 14 I'm a troubled kid I'm
vulnerable like this is kind of sketch I
don't even know what the story was true
but the way that he was crying it felt
real right you know what I mean like I
said he did the leg slap look away so I
was like yeah this is bad
um so he leaves our school
he uh he was a vice principal he leaves
our school becomes a principal of the
school right and we were all sad because
you know like up like that was the one
weird thing that was always in my mind
but otherwise he was the father you
forgot about that I forgot about it I
let it go you know I'm just a kid like
living life so he goes to another school
uh in a year uh no I want to say two and
a half years or so later
um
I'm watching news 12. oh wow wow I'm
watching news 12. no [__] and my mom
um
was watching it with me and they were
like oh uh principal of so and so was
arrested for lewd conduct with a boy uh
uh uh 15 years of age in his car with
one of his students and his [__]
picture pops up on the screen wow and
when I tell you my poor mother let out
the most blood curdling scream because
she knew how like close he was to me you
know what I mean and like my cut he was
close to my cousin he just like wanted
to [__] all of us I guess they just
wanted the whole bloodline so he was
just like you know [__] at night he's
like how many little priorities can I
[__] tonight that's what it was so my
mom lets out this blood curdling scream
and as soon as I saw his face it was
like you know what Shawshank Redemption
when he throws the rock through the
poster yeah yeah yeah yeah I knew it I
knew there was I just like I heard it
and The Rock just [__] bouncing
around I said this [__] went
through the wall so I just go I look at
the screen I just go I knew it I knew it
and now my phone just starts blowing up
right blowing up because everyone like
even like old teachers are calling me
they're like hey man like are you okay
but I know what they want to ask for
real right did you ever like suck his
[__] right you know what I mean like
that's what they want to ask me they're
just like yo you good man I know that's
a lot should we tell him bring them in
[Laughter]
so okay so that like has got real
[__] emotions right yeah dude and
they found like like uh he used to call
me
at night
and like I could hear him breathing
yeah yo he used to send me birthday
cards like every year
like send me letters and my dad being
the Italian guy that he is every time
like a letter he would call me be like
this guy's [__] gay yeah you know
like that's like where is Hector
yeah like Tampa Tony my dad would just
be like someone's not right about this
guy I think he's gay and I was just like
Dad he's just like a nice guy but gay
isn't the issue
[Laughter]
okay and pedophiles were the same thing
in their heads they were like they're
all doing this
I know he's a pedophile but with boys
you had sex with a little boy I knew he
was [__] gay
I'm gonna report this guy hey this guy
this guy is a gay he's a gay with my son
yeah I don't want to try and for being
gay
he's arrested for Penny whoa I don't
even know what that is yeah first degree
gang that's what he's got to get you on
if it's a girl
that mother got married when she was 12.
it's happened to the old country you
know this man had sex with your 13 year
old son I don't care about that yeah
it's okay get him out of here is my son
gay now like that's hurt by son gay yeah
so that so okay so so you literally that
happens and then so like what so what's
next then dude like the police yeah yeah
no no the police reached out to a couple
people uh but I kind of just like you
weren't cute enough I wasn't no dude I
was so cute when I was a kid like I
understood it I was like all right at
least he has good I picture you in this
outfit as a kid I think it's so cute
yeah just did it there yeah little like
Puerto Rican boxer
move on your cousin you said he talked
to your cousin no he he just like
befriended all of us he got the gayest
with me
like um in terms of like you know what
he talked about what did he even like
what did he
did he when he said I just don't want to
see that happen to you there's no he was
trying to bait it yeah he's grooming me
sure but no I know
during my push-ups in his mind logically
though in his mind he's like this
happened to me I just don't want to see
it happen to you it's like well who's
doing that to me yeah you know I mean
you like and then it doesn't make any
sense the craziest thing too is like
like all the girls like from my school
where they're all up there with like
free blank signs like there's no way
there's no way and I'm just in the
background like yeah there is yeah I was
like there could be a way oh so they he
was being immediately defended oh yeah
yeah our like entire like governing like
School body was like oh yeah like yeah
like no way no and I'm just there like
props you know what I mean yeah
and they were like uh I remember one
time they asked me they were like are
you gonna like come up and like hold the
sign or whatever I said I'm not getting
involved in any of this yeah yeah I was
like I'm not getting involved in any of
this and then my parents sat me down
they were like yo you just have to be
honest with us like did he ever do
anything and I was like nah I was too I
was too uh
I lost my virginity at 13. you know what
I mean so like I am yeah to him
[Laughter]
yeah yeah
I've been [__] them for a year right
yeah I already knew I already knew what
he was into because I helped him explore
that part but
so like so so you they're involved with
any of that stuff but then like but then
when you knew about it did you did were
you you said you were the only kid in
the neighborhood who who he did this
stuff with so like how did you feel when
you saw him get called were you like ah
[__] I wish you would have turned them
in back then do you have any guilt
feelings uh I'll be honest with you the
first thing I want to do is I wanted to
beat his face in the applesauce gets
angry yeah that was the first thing in
my mind I said right isn't gonna be good
for your weight loss for the wedding
that's true sugar is too high to
something more keto like a [__] like
uh like a celery puree yeah something
like that yeah or at least applesauce
with no artificial color flavor or added
sugar yeah sugar-free jello with sugar
yeah yeah it's aspartame you gotta watch
out for that too yes but I remember just
being like I'm gonna [__] kill this
guy like in my mind I was like yo I'm
gonna go to the courthouse and like
[__] uh who's the guy that shot um
Lee Harvey Oswalt oh yeah
Abraham Lincoln wait who shot Leon oh
Jack Ruby the Jack Ruby got killed I was
like I'm gonna [__] Jack Ruby this
guy yeah because
I the the the two like most important
male figures in my life at that were my
father and this guy yeah right you know
what I mean so I was like yo this guy
all the stuff that he did for me I'm
struggling with did it was it predicated
on this dude just one of my butt cheeks
or like did this guy really like me was
it both so like yeah I was like
traumatized for like five years after
that of course yeah I didn't trust I
didn't trust like anybody that like came
into my life and was like trying to help
me I was just so arrogant I just thought
everyone wanted to have sex with me wow
what was his fate did he go to prison he
so he didn't go to prison but he um he
didn't he took a plea though and as soon
as I heard I said yo if you're innocent
why are you taking a plea bro like that
that in my mind sure if you're innocent
why are you taking a plea if someone
said to me hey what's up you were in a
car with a 14 year old boy and it wasn't
true I'm going to [__] Court forever
right I'm starting to gofundme's
patreons to get funding I'm getting
[__] Johnny Cochran who was alive at
the time right I'm beating this [__]
case right so when he took the plea I
was like this just confirmed everything
for me so he lost his license and I go
my my cousin Googled him like a few days
ago he's an author now
wow a few days ago like two days ago
yeah like a few days ago so that's why
it's that's why it's just crazy that you
guys brought it like brought up that
type of thing but like uh so yeah so now
he's so now he's and then past that like
no probably nobody even knows it existed
back at that part of his life no no like
uh he goes by like a different name
self-employed self-employed right
self-employed we had to go and uh I also
saw he wrote a children's book what no
about about like the government yeah a
children's book about the government
yeah it sounds like a good idea yeah
yeah did you but but so and you and you
but but it's interesting because because
you still won't say his name and the
reason why you don't want to get sued
you don't want to bring you just don't
want to go through it again yeah it's
not it's public records like you could
Google it and like you know it's not
that hard to do it's just like for me
that part of my like uh like first
couple years of high school were like
ruined for me you know because I was
just like I was already a troubled kid I
was already having issues at home and
then the one guy that was like supposed
to do this gets arrested for like
sending [__] lewd messages and having
a boy in his car and doing all this [__]
I was like yo and he used to call me on
the phone he wrote me a letter after he
oh my God he wrote me a letter after he
got arrested and you gotta be [__]
kidding me to get arrested oh yeah
he was like I want you to know
everything that you're like heard about
me like isn't true and I was just like
dudes
a handwritten letter a handwritten a
psycho a handwritten he knows that he
literally talked to you about that that
that that inappropriate stuff yeah which
which nobody nobody knew I didn't tell
anybody about that but we had a meeting
of like there were like four kids that
like were always like kind of in and out
of his office and we all [__] met up
we had like this weird like [__] like
Goonies meeting like survivors yeah yeah
we did we did and we and we all like
talked about it and got drunk and we
were just like and then it comes down is
that he was kind of sharing little
tidbits with multiple kids about like
weird sexual stuff that happened in his
life or like he would ask like I
remember he would ask them about sex and
like ask me if I was having sex like
weird [__] because he wanted to see how
far he could push it be like is did I
did I pick one who would be willing to
do stuff yes he's trying to test you
yeah yeah that's grooming he was yeah
because they said they found like mad
text messages and [__] I never saw the
text messages do not go to prison then I
don't understand I don't know he took a
plea I'll show you I'll show you the uh
the article yeah I have him on your
podcast I I would I would really yeah I
would have I would have him on my
podcast would just lie anyway though he
would just lie he wouldn't take that he
wouldn't do that you want to know what I
wanted to do I wanted to do this is how
[__] dramatic and attention uh [__]
I am I wanted to go to like one of his
book signings
and and just show up with the book and
tell them to sign it
wow and just see what he says he
probably wouldn't even recognize you
probably because you're a skinny mini
now yeah yeah he'd just be like you're
not the thick boy I wanted to do yeah
thick passionate uh Latino love with
well yeah dude I've uh I say in my heart
I'll never that's one person
I'm big on forgiveness I think a lot of
people deserve forgiveness in life but
that's one person I'll never forgive
when you said you and you'd hear his
breath do you mean like I thought it was
prank you and you didn't know it was him
oh you know he would just be like
and I was like this guy's jerking off in
the middle of talking to you yeah I mean
allegedly like in my mind I was like
this guy's probably [__] jerking off
while he's talking allegedly allegedly
you know what I mean uh jerking off like
while he's talking to me yeah [__] is
[__] crazy that's [__] nuts yep
yeah well I mean you know well thanks
for having me guys yes
and uh this is another another fun hey
babe
um right you know it's every guest we
have on tells the same story right I
mean he's just like we're in a garage
it's four guys yeah if I'm gonna come
clean it's gonna be in here I said
that's it do us a favor why don't you
lift a couple weights yeah yeah yeah you
guys want to do some push-ups for him so
when I walked into the basement though
um Sal said hey what's up it's nice to
meet you big dick to me because we've
met before oh I'm so sorry no no no no
no no no no no no I'm gonna tell you
would never do that no no it's it's a
great story it doesn't have a big dick
it's not bad no it's not bad it's not
bad no you want to know when someone yo
dude you're like I feel terrible no no
no no no no this is why it's funny it's
because I just went into it like yo it's
so nice to meet you too like I was so
scared I was just like yeah dude it's so
nice to meet you too I don't like to
make people feel awkward but this is why
okay
um this is a great moment in my life
when we actually met okay so uh I'm
friends with uh Mika's advantagead plays
uh hockey for the Rangers right yeah so
he's like hey like you want to go out
one night and I was like yeah we went
out to uh fat cab pussycat oh I remember
the night that he was there yeah so he
was trying to
no that was the other way around that
was the other way around all right that
was the other way yeah no you're right
you're right you're right you're right I
believe you're right I believe you're
right yeah but you know what I was gonna
say yeah yeah okay I remember him that
night I'm so sorry that I know I don't
even know if I met him but I know he was
in sitting around I was with Sam right
uh I was with Sam and Liz and that's how
Michelle wolf yeah Sam invited Mika okay
okay Sam's good guy so uh yeah yeah so
he was like yeah like come through and
I'm sitting at this table and like I'm
trying to figure out my life like in
this moment like I'm still figuring out
like what I want to do like I'm on the
basement yard with Joe but like I'm
still trying to like figure out what I
want to do with life
like I looked down
and I look up and it's [__] salvicano
like Sam Morel who's like on like coming
up like doing his thing uh Michelle wolf
who like just did like the
correspondence dinner [__] God for
he's there I'm like yo this is [__]
crazy and like Mika plays like
professional hockey and I'm just some
[__] like borderline molested Puerto
Rican guy
so I'm just like yo like this is like
Sal from the Impractical Jokers dude
like my grandma loves this guy you know
what I mean I was like you know like she
like Generations yeah that's what I'm
saying and I was like yo like
I mean I love the show too but like I'm
just like wow like this is kind of a
[__] crazy ass moment like uh right
for me and I remember just like seeing
the whole scene and being like I want to
be in this so bad like I want like I
want to be able to like come and sit
with my friends like after like doing a
set and like do the whole thing and uh I
remember like that was a big day for me
actually the first day I ever met you
being like this is like
like I just didn't feel worthy to be at
the table
well you weren't geez Louise yeah yeah
so you still are yeah
anything yet I agree you need to if you
really wanted to be funny you should
have let that President molest you and
then you'd be the funniest guy you could
ever imagine but because you wanted to
go another route yeah what happened was
he walked away with your funny yeah
because he sucked it right he sucked it
right out of me he sucked it right out
of me but no that was like that was
actually a big night for me
and uh yeah yeah yeah it was just
YouTube yeah did we both [__] yeah yeah
we talked about like shoes and um oh
dude he told you the molesting story
yeah actually yeah I actually told you
to set the exact story
but um and then I also used to work for
Caroline so when you guys used to come
and do shows yeah you guys know how you
had the extended stage yeah I used to
build that before you guys oh [__] yeah
all right
shout out Caroline Hirsch wow but see
that's interesting now it's like we're
all like in the same world yeah you
don't remember we all all of us are
guilty of that we don't you know what I
like I like butcher box instead of
getting in my car and you know what I
used to do sometimes I used to go out
and buy what I was going to eat that
night that day right and I'm always
making these trips to the store because
I never knew what I would want to have
right and so all of a sudden if I was
like I want to have a flank steak
tonight I didn't have any house I just
want to pick out a flank steak yeah let
alone supermarket's freezing cold yes in
that aisle yes and then the blank States
all the blood's all over it and I don't
know which to pick and what not to know
butcher box sends me all of my Meats
monthly
14 pounds plus of meat all free range
organic grass-fed all that stuff I don't
have to pick it out I don't have to
leave the house I don't have to know
what I'm doing I load it up I am stacked
for the month stacked and they and they
they do all the hard work for me and you
can customize what you want or you can
take a pre-planned box and you can pause
anytime you like right there's no
getting hurt I love it try it out get it
sent to you put your stuff in the
freezer you're stuck with every type of
meat you want when it runs out you hit
the button you get it again and you get
a range of high quality cuts that are
hard to come by at the grocery store at
the amazing value get 100 grass-fed beef
free range organic chicken pork raise
crate free and wild caught Seafood right
to your doorstep free shipping in the
continental United States there's no
surprise fees yes like I said plan
options can be curated and customized
and changed whenever you want they got a
special offering running just for our
listeners if you use the code hey babe
you're gonna get twenty dollars off your
first box all you have to do is sign up
at butcherbox.com
okay babe use the code hey babe twenty
dollars off your first box you can't
beat it all right ship station make ship
happen if you're running a business and
you don't have ship station I genuinely
I can't help you that it seems like it
integrates with all of your Social
platforms and all of your shops your
online shops and what it does is it will
give you the best price to determine
what platform you should be using to
ship your stuff that's I mean it's
invaluable stuff like that didn't happen
like that would be like a wish that
someone would have back in the day like
could you imagine that we could do this
from home yeah and we could find out
what the pricing is and use any single
way to mail anything on everything we do
online yeah this is more mind-blowing
than like the invention of the plane
it makes it easy to grow your business
by handling your orders from every
Marketplace in One dashboard and with
Enterprise solutions that make Warehouse
optimization easy ship station scales
when you do they got over 130 000
companies that have grown their
e-commerce business with ships that's
ridiculous come on lower your shipping
costs they make returns easy keep your
customers happy okay we started using it
when they started on us we started using
it on our website yes we love it we love
it absolutely and and here we go and
right now all you got to do is go to
shipstation.com put in the promo code
hey babe to sign up for your free 60-day
trial not one penny it is free
shipstation.com promo code hey babe free
60-day trial the discounts are insane
too up to 84 off I can't USPS I can't
even talk about it we can't talk about
it anymore
wow but see that's interesting I was
like we're all like in the same world
yeah yeah you don't remember
all of us are guilty of that we don't
you know it's just like who knows what
the hell was even going on in our mind
there was probably a million things
going on yeah no that's right I'll never
forget them now I never yeah no no no no
I mean I fail to be fair we meet people
all the time no that's what I'm saying
no no that's anybody if I meet someone
once I don't expect them to remember who
I am yeah the next time that was like
anyone four years ago wasn't it yeah
okay yeah maybe even more okay it might
have been like five five years the only
reason I remember is because I knew
there was a hockey player there and when
you said fat black yeah yeah yeah yeah
but you know what I'm talking about and
I know you're talking yeah and then when
this goes off we'll talk yeah yeah oh
yeah dude there's so much good stuff
there's so much we're gonna we're gonna
know about what they were talking about
who this guy was Google
yeah oh that's a hey baby yeah it's
gonna be a banger but yeah no I want to
take guesses on who the molesting is it
you can't guess someone who doesn't know
about how about I bring up like a
picture of five like
just guess the Molester
I like that
is that the name that should be the name
of the app yeah and then just put the
three of us up there like that
it's like put him behind this [__]
mirror and I'm just like that's him that
would be fun I mean I know we're making
light of it but good everything oh yeah
yeah yeah
I mean I know
can I ask you guys like a serious
question oh God please
when I first when I first when I first
met you you were doing hyenas yes and I
remember after that like we talked about
I remember you were like just so like
willing to like learn about like the
podcast business sure yeah and you were
like how do you guys do this like how do
you do that like what the [__] is
patreon like what is that like what is
this stuff you know but I always say
like yes I'm so I'm so inspired by you
and like what you're doing bro I'm in
the fountain blue like a week ago and
I'm just walking through yeah and I just
see this [__] idiot's face up there
like oh March 31st like he's gonna be
there almost sold out almost sold out
there it is cheap plug cheap plug but
like you know but I just remember just
being like
for you guys
you know you guys have hit like a you
know a pinnacle of success right like
let's let's just be honest you know what
I mean how do you guys kind of just like
stay motivated to keep like doing what
you guys are doing because like you
could have retired like after like
Impractical Jokers and just been like oh
no like I'm good like I'll just make
like TV appearances like go host some
[__] like he put all the money in
Bitcoin so he's gone
FTX
I mean I mean I don't I mean just uh
well first of all I love this is what I
want to do so I love it yeah one number
two
I don't know I I just I I have to work
you know we have we have to work I've
worked for the day I mean I'm you know I
even my extended family I you know I I
feel like I have to work for them and
just I don't know it's just it's not
like oh I got money and now I could just
Coast on it you know what I mean well I
think it's also like you know God please
well I was gonna say I think because for
for us and I grew up with that but the
money has always come second with this
right yeah oh yeah so sure always the
money it's always been we're doing it
you know I mean how many years when we
first started comedy I mean I you would
lose money I have to pay five bucks to
get on stage I have to you know go out
of my way to you know [__] Delaware
to get a show so the money always came
second so I think when you start it that
way when the money's always coming
second then you kind of the money is
just a byproduct of it like yeah am I
gonna get on a plane and go to Phoenix
now without you know a certain amount of
money no because I have a family and I
have a life but I would like that the
thing is is even if like you know you I
went and did all the shows and they were
like hey why don't going to give you
half the check I'd be upset but I'd be
like all right but the shows were good
like you always are worried about the
shows were good you want to you're it's
like an art form so like you're you're
not necessarily the money is just a
thing that that comes next and also you
know I'm sure the same for Sal it's like
we haven't hit anywhere near all our
goals yet right like for me it's harder
to see how does like Louie keep doing it
how does Chappelle keep doing it like
they what else do you want them to do a
show on Mars right right you know so but
like I still like want to get to MSG Sal
wants to you know well you've done MSG
with the guys
I used to have to stand out and promote
his shows for the New York for the
[__] New York Comedy Festival yeah oh
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
I used to print his posters I used to
print your posts no [__] I used to do
all that [__] man like it's just crazy
how it comes well it also comes you're
always nice thank you I mean you guys no
let me tell you how nice when you work
social media at a comedy club sorry guys
you know I know we're a tight-knit
community or whatever but there's some
comedians that are [__] dicks oh
really yeah yeah more names on the
patreon
dicks to you because they think they
don't need you yeah or but a lot of like
yeah and I would just being like yo like
okay like you know you like most times I
was like sent to the store because like
it wasn't the right bottle of like vodka
in there oh you know and like you like
ride or [__] that was super annoying and
like yeah so like there's some people on
there where I'm just like people know
them we know you've hear the same future
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm I'm
actually too timid I I well not two but
like I feel I never feel I'm
in a place that should be I never feel
like I like I don't have the confidence
that I see brand new Comics have more
confidence on me too yeah I'm talking
about a confidence thing but I would
never treat anyone like that no no no no
no no no but I mean God always treat the
people who you you always got to treat
people the same I remember my mom always
told me that like I don't know why like
I just remember her saying it to me she
was like you got to be careful in life
of who people who how they treat the
people they think they don't need if
they treat those people respectfully you
step away from those people I remember I
had a person who was uh worked in the in
my life that I was like I saw him
disrespect a waitress so much and then
be like you know whatever and like
nobody even noticed it but me I was like
I gotta find this guy tomorrow yeah and
I did wow yeah because because that's
like a huge thing yeah it is Big The
Company You Keep is is I would say 90 of
this thing it's having some kind of
success yeah but with the money no one's
got into comedy because they think
they're gonna make money no you know
they're getting into it because I feel
bad though because like uh like I I did
a a weekday I did two weekday shows at
Caroline's and sold out both and then I
did it again and I've done four shows
and sold them all out at Caroline so
it's like I have this like uh imposter
syndrome where it's like you know
not that I don't deserve it because like
I feel like I've worked really possum is
normal man yeah but I see like people
like when you see like Comics that want
to like do time bro like they're just
like happy for time well here you know
what I mean and I give time to Comics
like my first show I put like six comics
on before me because I was just like I
respect the art form so much right and I
was like yeah let's go go do five
minutes like what the [__] the business
but see the business part of it go after
that because the business is like you
know some people will say see a comic
who gets famous on like I don't know
Tick Tock or whatever and they sell out
all these shows and you'll have like
comedy purists being like well [__] them
[__] it's like you're not taking any
tickets away from the guy who's mad it's
like if your business is hot then you go
for the business yeah the thing about I
think what you want the thing about like
being in with like Sal and Sam and all
that that the the the that only will
happen with time there's no way around
the time like I had like I remember for
my my career I was doing
Guy Code and girl code and these shows
were so big and so popular and I felt
the same imposter syndrome it wasn't
until I got on the David Letterman show
and then started getting no like getting
recognized by like a Sam I'm like oh hey
that set was good even though you know I
made more money and sold more tickets
from Guy Code and gorkel then i f David
Letterman kind of came and went it's
like that validity that you need that
validation sorry that it's only ever
going to come with time but if the
business is hot go get the money because
that may not you might get the it's
interesting what could happen you might
get the validation from the comics that
you want because you finally reached
that time but the money is down you were
making more money now right it's a weird
thing that happens you know because like
I remember like just being in this room
like right now is like crazy to me like
you know what I mean just like uh but
like you know I've known you for a while
and you know it's just like you you know
I thought I knew you until I heard the
what you told me yeah yeah yeah now you
know me even more yeah but I did I
filmed your Caroline show and I wouldn't
have guessed it that you had just
started stand up yeah yeah oh did you
just start yeah I just started like
three months ago
yeah yeah all right I started like three
months ago and uh Caroline
is closed so bad that everybody left but
you know it was a great show I wouldn't
have guessed thank you so much yeah any
ghost stories do you believe in ghosts
do I believe in ghosts hell yeah dude
first of all my mother's Puerto Rican I
believe in ghosts right you know my mind
is too yeah if you have my kids are if
there's any lap yeah I think if you know
allegedly right baby mama allegedly I
think
Hispanic or latinx I don't want to get
in trouble uh whatever
um Women Believe in like the
supernatural more than anybody else oh
yeah like like a Puerto Rican woman will
break up with you just because like she
sees like a fingerprint on a picture
frame you know what I mean like that
wasn't there like you're cheating on me
I'm leaving yeah like you know like
Spanish women are very uh uh into the uh
what is it the not the afterlife thing
no I know that's paranormal that's why I
have a Puerto Rican girl every great
joke every girl I cheat with I ask them
ask them to wear gloves now
and I'm just just in case yeah it is
they're wearing gloves like pimp yeah
yeah yeah that great AOC joke that's a
great joke yeah yeah yeah if it's true
if the NYPD just hired all female
Hispanic detectives no crime would be
like yeah it's true because they they
watch and um and yeah but I so wait so
you're saying you have a goat but do you
have an actual ghost story Latino women
no I do I was I was sleeping I was
sleeping in my friend's house Croatian
kid uh Crazy
R to cashmere yeah yeah pretty much I
like that yeah but he's uh he's six foot
nine okay with this material is
all crush
this is all Crush crunch how old are you
uh probably like 20. oh okay yeah I'm
like 20 and and I'm sleeping alone in
his basement
and I swear to God I just start to hear
like these Baltic like like women like
chanting
like uh just be like
[Music]
and I'm letting it go and I'm like all
right it's basement noise it's basement
noise go to sleep it's basement noise
like I'm trying to tell myself there's
some [__] you're alone down there you're
afraid I'm alone I'm alone you're
thinking this is Kevin McAllister yeah
so yeah yeah so I'm alone down there and
I'm like
okay and now it's to the point where
like I don't know if this was like my
first night of sleep paralysis ever
maybe but like I literally heard the
[__] get closer like
like you're speaking like [__]
Croatian and Serbian or some [__] and
it's like getting closer and closer and
closer to me and I jump out of the bed
and I run upstairs and I tell Craig I'm
like yo there's [__] someone
downstairs bro yeah there's somebody in
there like one of your [__] uncles is
like sleeping down there like some
[__] crazy [__]
so time goes on and I'm hanging out with
my brother Michael and a couple other
people when they all slept there they
had the same experience
whoa and they all ran up to krezmir's
room no and we're like yo this
[__] ghost is down here bro and
we all had like just like how we had to
crash me he doesn't want to hear it no
crashmir is like yo like and we would go
down there we tried to like catch it on
like on night vision
his mom had like remember those big ass
jvcs they used to have like night vision
on it we like set it up one night and
crashed me up could it have been he was
messing with you or no no no no you
think he had people in his basement
chained up yeah dude I mean Croatia we
all know Croatia yeah they're down there
making [__] buddhaq and [__] yeah
they're doing like all kinds of crazy
yeah they're wild people so I was like
this is like one of his cousins that's
like not supposed to be here illegally
so I was like and he's just making
noises at night but I'm telling you I
don't know if it was like sleep
paralysis or whatever like something
weird was going on but once you get in
the mind of like there's a ghost yeah
man there's a [__] ghost yeah no
one's gonna be able to convince me that
there aren't like some kind of ghostly
figures because if you really think
about it we don't know [__] about
science it's true it's true about this
or urge for this yeah this is and I it's
fine because I won't say any names so
the house that we live in right the
ghost molest of you here yes yes
we're all friends yes he kept going vice
president
so so let's do push-ups so this so this
this house so the the previous owners or
maybe two owners ago but like you know
the neighbors have been living here on
in this in this area for a while the
neighbors yeah the the previous owner or
I don't know if it's the previous owner
or two owners ago his wife died suddenly
right they don't know if she was sick
whatever but they think there's two like
things that would go around either that
you know he killed her
or she commits suicide somewhere in this
house and we got the kitchen remodeled
and since we've opened up the walls
Jasmine again Latina hears like a
woman's voice in the house almost all
the time and then when when for some
reason like not TT Jerry no no it's not
Titi Jared it's not no shout out TT
Jerry
and um and so and so so
when we went and went out to dinner with
these with these neighbors and they told
that story and Jazz like got like pale
white because she was like I literally
she was like like she was like my skin
is like she was like my hair is like she
literally had like a reaction like in
the dinner because she was like oh my
God she was like literally she got like
a ghost rash Ghost Ranch like she was
like like I'll just coin that yeah I did
I like that ghost rash I'll never forget
where we were I'll never forget where I
was because you know we had just heard
that like I I hadn't even known that
stuff yet and then they could just say
it they're like yeah it's crazy and then
Jasmine was like that and she was like
literally she was like for the past week
every single night she was like I get
woken up and I and I would see her get
woken up but like again that's super
nice thing she would get woken up and
she would be like this has been hey babe
laughs
[Music]
don't be a flight
say hey babe hey babe hey babe hey babe
hey babe